[Musik]
herzlich willkommen hier bei Bild die
richtigen Fragen kommen von ihnen heute
von unseren Zuschauern und Lesern hier
bei Bild die richtigen Fragen an die
Bundesbildungsministerin an Bettina
stark Watzinger herzlich Willkommen an
sie sehr gerne fehlt ihnen was beim
Thema Bildung ein worin wir deutschen
eigentlich richtig richtig gut sind
zumindest ist es so dass bei uns die
Schule ja eine lange Tradition hat sie
ist allerdings
ja gut das hat sich sehr viel geändert
und die Schule muss ich jetzt auch
ändern und das ist ja das worüber wir
wahrscheinlich heute sprechen ja ich
wollte aber wissen was richtig richtig
gut läuft da muss man schon lange
überlegen ne also was läuft eigentlich
in im bundesbildungsland Deutschland im
einzigen richtig gut wo rum beneidet uns
die ganze Welt ja gut man hat ja schon
früh festgestellt dass eben dieser
Zugang zu Bildung für alle also diese
dieses humbolsche Ideal das war schon
hier ausschlaggebend aber sie merken
schon ich bin in der Vergangenheit
vergangen genau also ich stell einmal
fest es gibt nichts worum uns die Welt
in Sachen Bildung beneidet richtig
nichts würde ich nicht sagen weil also
wir sind im international Ranking müssen
wir Gas geben aber natürlich gibt es
Regionen in den Bildung nicht den
Stellenwert hat jedenfalls
gibt auch Länder die uns beneiden aber
wir sollten ja uns eher darum bisschen
damit beschäftigen wo wir hinwollen und
nicht unsere vergleichen um die Schulen
natürlich gibt es Länder die nicht die
Finanzen haben die die nicht die
Tradition haben die vielleicht auch noch
mal eine ganz andere Bandbreite haben
die gar nicht die Infrastrukturen haben
aber noch mal wir brauchen ein Update da
muss schon weit fahren
dass uns um die Schulen beneidet die
Fragen kommen von unseren Zuschauern von
unseren Lesern heute und eine kommt von
Aische Wilhelms aus Trier
Rheinland-Pfalz Mutter von zwei Kindern
schreibt sie dazu und außerdem Klassen
Elternsprecherin und sie schreibt unsere
Schule ist ein in einem erbärmlichen
Zustand es Herr Platzmangel so dass ein
Kellerraum als ersatzklasse genutzt wird
und Container steht auf dem Schulhof
dadurch entfällt im Moment der Pausenhof
schreibt sie hier sehen wir sie auch
Aische Wilhelms und sie schreibt
außerdem gibt's zu wenig Toiletten für
die Schüler die Decke im zweiten
Stockwerk ist feucht es regnet sogar
rein die Fenster kaputt aufgeweicht von
der Feuchtigkeit und so weiter und so
fort empfinden sie bei so einer
Schilderung Scham das ist mangelnder
Respekt gegenüber den jungen Menschen
auch den Lehrerinnen und Lehrern die
dort arbeiten und das ist die Zukunft
unseres Landes und eigentlich ist das
das einfachste Thema dass wir am
schnellsten abschaffen könnten oder eine
Lösung finden könnten nämlich einmal
Farbe durchzugehen und was zu bauen
aber darüber diskutieren wir ja
mittlerweile seit Jahrzehnten über genau
solche Schulen vielleicht können wir
noch ein paar Bilder zeigen die uns Frau
Willems geschickt hat bei denen wir eben
noch mal sehen wie es an den Decken
aussieht in den Gängen aussieht und so
weiter Bruchbude schreibt sie das trifft
glaube ich ganz gut wenn wir die
Ausschnitte hier zumindest aus der
Schule in Trier sehen die bundesweit
natürlich solche Bilder aus Schulen und
sie schreibt noch mal durchgehen also zu
wenig Toiletten kein pausenhofen
Klassenzimmer im Keller die
Deckenfenster kaputt und so weiter
müssen in unserem Land ganz ehrlich
sagen sorry für das haben wir gerade
kein Geld das ist ja sehr
unterschiedlich der Schulbau und
Unterhalt liegt ja bei den Kommunen und
die Finanzkraft ist sehr unterschiedlich
aber es darf eigentlich nicht vom Zufall
abhängen wo ich lebe welche Schuh
Chancen und auch in welchem Umfeld mein
Kind zur Schule geht und deswegen ist
das ein Thema das eigentlich alle vor
Ort anpacken müssen aber wie würden sich
das erklären das ist immer noch solche
Schulen oder immer wieder solche Schulen
gibt ich weiß Sie sind jetzt
logischerweise in Rheinland-Pfalz für
diese Schule nicht verantwortlich und
gleichsam
Bundesbildungsministerin sie
die Antworten in großen Haushalt völlig
klar dass man irgendwie sich
verantwortlich fühlen wird in ihrer
Rolle für solche Zustände das heißt wie
erklären sich überhaupt dass es das gibt
in Deutschland
Bildung ist etwas bei dem man den
Eindruck gewinnt dass diejenigen den es
wichtig ist und die sich darum kümmern
können dann auch ihre Stimme erheben
aber das ist eben nicht in allen Teilen
so und deswegen ist es umso wichtiger
dass die die vor Ort Verantwortung
tragen dann auch hinschauen und vor
allen Dingen auch die Abhilfe schaffen
weil wie gesagt für die Kinder ist es
kein Zustand dort zu lernen und wir
werden auch keine Lehrerin und Lehrer
finden die dort hingehen und deswegen
muss das Bewusstsein nicht nur in der
Sonntagsrede sein sondern ist montags im
Haushalt steht es glaube ich ganz gut ne
jahrelang genauso passiert und dann eben
solche Bilder ich fühle mich gerade da
ein bisschen hilflos was sollen wir
jetzt machen mit Frau Wilhelms also wir
haben versprochen sie können Ihre Fragen
einsenden wir hören Sie jetzt was sollen
wir jetzt Willems Antworten also bleibt
halt so ist gerade kein Geld da Pech sie
wohnen in der falschen Kommune oder was
die Antwort das darfst du nicht bleiben
nichtsdestotrotz kann ich gar nicht dort
einschreiten und ich habe auch gar nicht
die finanziellen Mittel das ist ja bei
uns so dass die Aufgaben im
Bildungssystem verteilt sind und auch in
den entsprechenden in der Kommune im
Land und dem Bund für bestimmte Dinge
das Geld da ist und deswegen kann ich
nur sagen die Leute vor Ort die Eltern
vor Ort die Bürgerinnen und Bürger vor
Ort das sieht ja jeder müssen das zu
einem wichtigen Thema machen das eben
nicht wieder zur Seite geschoben werden
kann sondern dass dann auch wirklich
Auswirkungen in der Politik vor Ort hat
ich glaube
dass sie Recht haben in der Formulierung
das muss zu einem wichtigen Thema
gemacht werden in der Politik weil das
ja anscheinend nicht ist sonst würde man
mit den Schulen nicht so umgehen oder es
ist nicht wichtig genug bisher die Frage
stellen wir uns ja oft weil
Bildungspolitik etwas ist bei denen
jeder relativ schnell ja sagt aber
natürlich die Frage der Investitionen in
Bildung ich finde das ist eine
Investition sollte auch in der
Haushaltsordnung als Investition gelten
weil sie die Grundlage für die Zukunft
ist und leider muss es oft erst relativ
drastisch werden bis dann auch klar ist
dass diese Investition die eben nicht
heute und nicht morgen vielleicht sofort
sichtbar ist sondern langfristig wird
das muss auch auf der politischen Agenda
ganz oben stehen ich glaube allen Eltern
allen Lehrern den Schülern ist das total
klar ehrlich gesagt absolut mir ist es
aber auch klar
warum gibt es kein 100 Milliarden Euro
Sondervermögen die Frage kommt immer
wieder von den Lesern von den Zuschauern
wie bei der Bundeswehr warum gibt es das
nicht längst für Bildung warum machen
sie sich nicht dafür stark ja das kann
ich natürlich verstehen also man
vergleicht ja immer die verschiedenen
Politikbereiche aber ein Sondervermögen
von 100 Milliarden auf der Bundesebene
würde nicht die Schulen vor Ort sanieren
weil wir das gar nicht dürfen ja sondern
das macht ja der Bildungsträger ich habe
keine direkte Beziehung mit der mit
Moment mit der Kommune ja 100 Milliarden
wenn man die verteilen würde wenn man
das Geld frei machen würde da würde die
Schule in Trier ja nicht sagen Moment da
greifen wir jetzt nicht rein da würde
das Land Rheinland-Pfalz ja nicht sagen
da wollen wir jetzt nichts haben weil
der Bundeswehr nicht zuständig ja der
Bund unterstützt ja auch schon bei
vielen Leben z.B bei der digitalen
Infrastruktur haben wir einen Pakt
gemacht aber noch mal es gibt eine
Aufgabenteilung und so sind ja auch die
Finanzen zugeordnet noch mal ein
Beispiel das ist jetzt nicht die Schule
aber die Hochschule das ist ja auch ein
Bildungsort dort gab es im Rahmen einer
Föderalismusreform haben die Länder
gesagt wir wollen das als unsere Aufgabe
sie dafür auch umsatzsteuerpunkte
zugewiesen bekommen in Milliardenhöhe
das heißt dort ist das Geld hingeflossen
wenn ich das Geld wieder zurückbekomme
dann können wir natürlich auch darüber
sprechen wer trägt die Verantwortung
aber Finanzierung und Verantwortung
gehören eben zusammen das heißt sobald
sie da rein regieren dürfen dann würden
Sie sagen okay dann schießen wir viel
mehr Geld rein in die Schulen dann
müsste man aber auch über Aufteilung der
Steuermittel sprechen wir weil das was
wir an Steuern zahlen wird jetzt
zwischen Kommune Land und Bund
aufgeteilt entsprechend den Aufgaben und
jeder muss seine Prioritäten setzen
Problem ist nur ich verstehe schon dass
sie nichts bezahlen können wenn sie oder
wollen wenn sie nicht mitreden wollen
andererseits verstehst du auch nicht
weil das wird hier weiter auf dem Rücken
der Schüler und Lehrer ausgetragen
solange sie sich über Zuständigkeiten
zoffen passiert halt verordnet auf jeden
Fall vollkommen Recht die Leute haben
keine Lust dass wir uns über
Zuständigkeiten streiten davon ist auch
noch kein Kind klug geworden und keine
Schule gebaut worden nichtsdestotrotz
ich meine wenn ich nicht wählen lassen
dann habe ich auch eine Verantwortung
für etwas und wenn ich mich vor Ort auch
wählen lassen und den Schulträger dann
habe ich auch die Verantwortung
ordentliche Schulen hinzustellen